behind the darkened Windows of the cars
are men suspected of smuggling the
migrants who drowned in the
Mediterranean last week they arrived at
a courthouse in Kalamata on Tuesday
morning for their arraignment hearing
nine men all from Egypt are being held
by Greek police as with the rest of them
he denies the accusations and he denies
any involvement in the actions related
to the charges and he claims he is
innocent he claims he was with 30 to 35
Egyptian compatriots on the boat he left
his country looking for a better life in
Europe because of economic difficulties
this is some of the last known footage
of the boat filmed from the air by
European border and Coast Guard agency
frontex it shows a fishing trawler
packed with people perhaps as many as
750. the refugees and migrants were on
their way from Libya to Italy when their
boat capsized and sank off Greece's
southern coast most of them were from
Syria Pakistan and Egypt only 104 are
known to have survived
those fortunate few are now confined to
a migrant camp near Athens people have
come from across Europe to see if
missing relatives are among them we've
come from bologna and we've managed to
speak to guys who survived there are 12
Pakistani boys and we showed them the
photo of our cousin to see if it was one
of them Unfortunately they confirmed to
us that he was on the boat Rescuers
recovered 90 corpses and now we have to
see with the photos if we can recognize
one of these people as our cousin
for others the agonizing search has had
Happier Endings
while relatives wait mourn or Rejoice
questions are being asked some people
are criticizing the eu's Asylum policies
as chaotic and a contributing factor in
frequent migrant drownings and some are
asking whether Greece might be covering
something up they say ship tracking logs
for the area suggest the boat's final
movements weren't what the Greek Coast
Guard claims Greek officials have yet to
respond
Rory challenge Al Jazeera